معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره امين
درغامي امين انقسامات واضحه بين الساسه
الاسرائيليين وكذلك حديث يكثر عن ضغط
امريكي لعلك تشرح لنا كل
ذلك صحيح عثمان هذه الخلافات التي بدت
واضحه وتزداد حدتها يوما بعد اخر سواء بين
اعضاء الحكومه الاسرائيليه او بين اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده امريكيه من جهه اخرى
بخصوص مستقبل صفقه تبادل الاسرى بين
اسرائيل وحركه حماس هذه الصفقه التي وبحسب
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه اليوم قالت بان
اربعه وزراء من حزب الليكود الذي يتراس
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو اعربوا خلال
الاجتماع الحكومي الذي امتد الى ساعه
متاخره من الليله الماضيه عن رفضهم لهذا
الاتفاق اذا ما خرج عن اطار الاتفاق الاول
مع حركه حماس والذي يقضي باطلاق سراح
ثلاثه اسرى مقابل كل اسير فلسطيني طبعا كل
هذا ياتي وسط حديث عن ضغوطات امريكيه
متزايده على حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو من اجل
القبول بصفقه قد تتجاوز اربعه اشهر وهي من
مرحلتين المرحله الاولى تقضي باطلاق سراح
35 محتجزا واسيرا اسرائيليا لدى فصائل
المقاومه في غزه مقابل اطلاق عدد من
الاسرى الفلسطينيين الذين تعد محكومياتهم
ليست بالكبيره وايضا وقف لاطلاق النار
وانسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه من مراكز
المدن في قطاع غزه وبعد ذلك ستكون هناك
مرحله ثانيه ستشمل العسكريين الاسرى
الاسرائيليين لدى فصائل المقاومه مقابل
اطلاق
سراح اسرى فلسطينيين محكومياتهم طبعا
كبيره وهم من قاده الفصائل الفلسطينيه
ويتبع ذلك وقف لاطلاق النار وتمتد هذه
الهدنه الى اكثر من اربعه اشهر والجزء
الثاني في الحقيقه من هذه الصفقه التي
تتحدث عنها وسائل الاعلام هي التي تثير
الجدل ومن المنتظر ان تلقى رفضا لدى عدد
من اعضاء الحكومه الاسرائيليه طبعا كل ذلك
ياتي وسط تزايد حده الخلافات مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عشيه وصول وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن الى
اسرائيل غدا الثلاثاء ولقائه طبعا المرتقب
مع المسؤولين الاسرائيليين وما سبق ذلك من
مشاحنات سواء من خلال
تلك يعني الانتقادات
و الحديث الذي صدر امس عن بين كفير الذي
انتقد فيه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وما
تلاه ايضا من انتقادات لشخص بين كفير
ووقوف رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو موقف
وسط اذا صح تعبير هو لم ينتقد صراحه
تصريحات وفي المقابل مع امين والى هذه
الكلمه لا تمار بن جفير وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي ان يكون ذلك فقط مقابله تعامل
انساني الجمله الاخرى لرئيس الحكومه اعلم
انك الان على مفترق
وربما عليك ان تختار هناك
طريق اولى هي طريق المجلس الوزاري المصغر
طريق التصور القديم الذي مضيت عملتم فيه
طريق الاحتواء وعدم
الحسم الطريق الذي يتقبل دوله فلسطينيه
كامر مفروغ
منه الطريق التي اثبتت مره تلو الاخرى
اخطاها بذاتها ولكن هناك طريق اخرى طريق
القوه اليهوديه حزبنا قوه يهوديه طريق
الحسم طريق الاخضاع
التدمير
حماس والتوقف عن منحهم
الوقود طريق كانت سوف تسلكها اي دوله اخرى
طبيعيه عليكم ان تقولوا اذا اردتم مساعدات
انسانيه اذا اخرجوا لنا رنا تريدون معامله
انسانيه فقط مقابل تعامل
ارجو ان يقوم رئيس الحكومه بحسم الامر وان
يختار طريق قوه يهوديه لا طريق لبيد و
شكرا نعود الى امين درغامي في تل ابيب
استمعت ربما هذا الجزء من الكلمه لا تمار
بن كفير وطبعا هو الاكثر تشددا وكان ملفتا
وصف يا اير لابيد له بانه
مهرج يريد اشعال النار
هذه هذه المواقف المتباينه بشده كيف يمكن
ان تؤثر على تماسك الحكومه وبالتالي
مواقفها عثمان نعم الخطاب المتشدد الذي
يصدر عن اتمار بنفير منذ فتره اضافه الى
حليفه سموتريتش طبعا انعكس بشكل كبير على
الحكومه فهو لطالما كان يهدد
بالانسحاب من الحكومه اذا ما وافقت على
صفقه اطار لتبادل
الاسرى تعطي حصانه لحركه حماس او تقضي
بعدم استرجاع كل الاسرى والمحتجزين
الاسرائيليين لدى فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه او حتى وقف الحرب والانسحاب من
قطاع غزه اثارت تصريحات بنفير طبعا الكثير
من الجدل في اسرائيل ووجهت بردود فعل سواء
من معسكر
الدوله او ايضا من قبل زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه وكانت كل هذه التصريحات تدعو
نتنياهو الى ضبط بنفير الذي تمادى في
انتقاداته للولايات المتحده واعتبرت
تصريحاته بانها س تضر من جهه بمصالح
اسرائيل الاستراتيجيه ومن جهه اخرى ايضا
بالعلاقات مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي قدمت وما تزال دعما سخيا لاسرائيل
منذ احداث السابقه
من اكتوبر طبعا تصريحات بنكبر الان تاتي
في هذا السياق هو اليوم فقط كان قد انتقد
البنوك الاسرائيليه التي عملت على تجميد
حسابات بعض ممن فرضت عليهم عقوبات امريكيه
هم من طبعا المستوطنين في ذلك القرار
الامريكي الذي صدر قبل ايام وهو الان يقول
بان هناك مشاكل داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وداخل مجلس الح حرب في التعامل مع الاداره
الامريكيه وكان يتحدث بان اسرائيل دوله
ذات سياده ويمكنها ان تتخذ مواقفها وايضا
ان تتخذ ما تراه مناسبا بالنسبه لها وهي
ليست خاضعه لاي احد في اشاره واضحه الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ونعلم جيدا ان
جذور هذا الخلاف بين الحكومه الحاليه خاصه
المشكله من اليمين المتطرف الاسرائيلي
لديها
يعني لنقل مشاكل كبيره مع الاداره
الامريكيه تمتد الى ما قبل الحرب على قطاع
غزه اليوم هناك تصريحات كانت قد نقلتها
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه نقلا عن الرئيس
الامريكي الذي هاجم رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو في حديثه وايضا هناك انتقادات
صريحه وواضحه لهذه الحكومه التي ترى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انها عائق
امام يعني التوصل الى اي صفقه مستقبليه
بشان وقف الحرب او وقف اطلاق النار او
تبادل الاسرى مع تصاعد هذا الخطاب خاصه
الصادره عن بن كفير وسموت شكرا جزيلا لك
امين درغامي من تل ابيب